77th division was entrapped by German
forces history professor Robert Farrell
tells the story in his new book five
days in october the lost battalion of
World War one he spoke about it at the
Liberty Memorial Museum in Kansas City
Missouri for about 50 minutes
welcome my name is Eli Paul and I'm the
museum director of the Liberty Memorial
Museum of World War one we're here today
in the museum's new JC Nichols
auditorium for the third and last of our
Liberty for all lectures the first
lecture Illustrated how the cataclysmic
events of 1914 through 1918 affected the
art and artists of world war one
especially those who experienced it
firsthand the second lecture revealed
how the war affected one young cub
reporter from the Kansas East are by the
name of Ernest Hemingway and how his
wartime experiences influenced his later
writings especially the novel of
farewell to arms today we're shifting
from art and literature to the
battlefields of Europe to the Western
Front and how the war affected one group
of American soldiers our guide for that
journey is dr. Robert Farrell the
distinguished historian now living in
Michigan who will discuss his new book
on the famous lost battalion of the 77th
division Robert Farrell is professor
emeritus of history at Indiana
University in Bloomington because his
research interests have brought him so
often to Missouri and Kansas
particularly to our museums library and
archives we like to think of him as an
honorary Kansas City topics for his
books include the private writings of
Harry Truman the relationship between
Truman and boss Tom Pendergast the war
record of the 35th division which was
composed primarily of Missouri and
Kansas men and the presidency of Calvin
Coolidge who holds a special place in
our heart here because he was the
president at the 1926 opening of the
Liberty Memorial and attended that if
you look on the website on the
University of Missouri press and search
for his name the titles of seventeen
works come up not Calvin Coolidge dr.
Farrell
a list of books that he has written
edited or introduced it is an honor for
us that he's come here to speak on his
latest contribution to that list his new
book is five days in october the lost
battalion of world war one please
welcome dr. Sarah
[Applause]
mr. Paul ladies and gentlemen I am
delighted to be here I'm surprised that
there is such a large audience here and
I like to think that this shows that
World War 1 1917-18 for the United
States that was our time of activity
that this is a point of fascination for
I think all Americans I sometimes
believe or seem to have evidences that
World War one is not that interesting
some of my Indiana University students
could not really updated American
participation in World War 1 i'm sorry
to say this but that is true if you
asked I'm afraid the average American
what the meuse-argonne was they probably
could not tell you and almost certainly
could not tell you the date but this
group here says to me that there is much
interest in this war which itself was a
fascinating affair it's a great
privilege to be here at the Liberty
Memorial and I said a few words last
night about what the memorial was like
when I first came here which was 25 and
more years ago it was not in very good
condition but the citizens of Kansas
City have contributed an enormous amount
the general told me last night 100
million dollars which has gone into this
great museum which now has been
designated the museum for 1917-18 it is
of course a great ornament of the city
of Kansas and together with the art
museum and then the creation of that
wonderful president of the United States
the great harry s truman there's the
Truman library out to the east in
perhaps what one might describe is
greater kansas city that is independence
those three places
but particularly now since we are here
today the Liberty Memorial is a great
privilege to be here and see this
institution under general burg risers
guidance and that of his predecessors
and those of eli paul the two great
galleries here which are art deco in
their decoration of the 1920s are just
wonderful places and they are in
beautiful order no thanks again to the
citizens of Kansas City I want to thank
also my publisher miss Beverly Jarrett
who is here today she is a wonderful
person for whom to work and take part in
her publishing activities she has
published now I think between a thousand
and fifteen hundred books and they're
all good books but I'm not speaking
about my books I should mention that but
with those exceptions they are good
books she publishes good books she is
now working with the Liberty Memorial to
institute a series of books on world war
one of which my book I believe may be
the first I hope there will be a whole
series and Beverly is certainly working
in that direction I thank Beverly for
all of her assistance over now a very
considerable amount of time speaking
about the lost battalion let me start
first by saying what I think its
importance is what it says to me is that
ordinary Americans if they get into a
corner if they get into a tight place
these ordinary Americans are people upon
whom you can rely this is one of the
great qualities of the country and we
have been in a series of tight places
ever since the morning of april six 1972
1917 that morning President Woodrow
Wilson was at breakfast
the word came that the joint resolution
had come down from the hill and he
excused himself with his people at the
breakfast table and went into a small
alcove near the front of the White House
and there he signed the resolution and
he sent 50,000 young men to their deaths
this was the opening of what you might
describe not the numerical centuries but
this was the opening of our century
which I think still continues you have
World War One World War two Korea
Vietnam of course and now Iraq and
terrorism I've heard sometimes among my
university professor friends that the
world is going to the dogs or the cats
and they seem to think that the country
is in awful shape it's not an awful
shape not with the kinds of Americans
who took part in the lost battalion and
some of the episodes before that in Ann
Arbor I go across a little bridge on the
Huron River the urine river is not a
large river but the bridge was built in
1876 and this was the date of the Battle
of the Little Bighorn and before that
there was the Alamo and then in 1918
five days October second to October
seventh it was a Wednesday through the
following Monday those five hundred and
fifty men in the pocket it was a piece
of heroism just sheer heroism and nobody
tried to get out except those
individuals who went out looking for
food which if they had found it which
they did not they would have brought it
back in it was a testimony to what
ordinary Americans can do and I think we
can take this in our lives today when we
are facing all of these problems the
great problems internationally opened on
april six 1917
so I pass to the lost battalion it was
10 minutes 21 on Wednesday afternoon and
six companies of the first and second
battalions 30 8th Infantry Regiment
moved up a wide ravine the meuse-argonne
the battle for which that great sector
began on sep tember 26 1918 the mirror
gun was not a nice place to fight and
particularly the Argonne forest the jump
off point for the 77th division which
was the division of the 308 and when it
came in the next morning the 30 seventh
company k that the rears are gun was a
tangle of ravines and woods and bushes
and some of the ravines had Heights that
approach the definition of cliffs and
there was one of the regulars a regular
officer who had been in the Philippines
and he said that the mere Zargon
resembled none of the jungles in the
Philippines it was worse so on the early
afternoon of October 72 second those six
companies went up it was a wide ravine
it moved to the north the 77th division
sector which was all of the Argonne
forest halfway up where they jumped off
the sector the sector was seven and a
half kilometres wide and that was five
miles and there were 28 thousand men or
something approaching that when the
division jumped out it the companies
went up and it was a ravine that was
half a mile across and they went up on
the eastern side of the ravine it moved
north the best the best way to
understand the tactical situation is to
consider a capital letter T they went up
the stem they went up for one
kilometer which was five eighths of a
mile they started that nearly one
o'clock and it took them until five
thirty and they had to go up very slowly
because the Germans had sharpshooters on
the west side of the ravine and if the
men came out into the open they tried to
stay under the trees and hidden somehow
but there were four hundred and fifty of
them k company had the additional number
that took the full strength of the the
men in the what became a pocket to 550
if those four hundred and fifty men were
caught in the open there would be a
crack and a man almost certainly would
fall they took 88 casualties going up
there were eight men killed and eighty
wounded which in the force of 450 is
pretty serious but general Alexander who
was the division commander told them to
go on up there and he passed the word to
the brigade commander who was general
Ivan Johnson & Johnson passed it on down
to Colonel Cromwell Stacy who commanded
the 308 and Stacy told major Charles W
whittlesea who was the commander of the
force going up to take his men up there
his second-in-command was Captain George
G McMurtry the group was led by
whittlesea and McMurtry it was a
half-mile wide this ravine they got up
to thurs three-fourths of the way
suffering these casualties carrying
their dead and the wounded and they came
to a German trench line it was not
really a line it was two trenches too
short trenches 111 going up each side of
the ravine and the place in the middle
which should have been to use the word
of the time wire that is filled with
barbed wire was open and no one was
there so all the men had to do was file
down to the bottom of the ravine and
passed through this line and i should
say here that in the mirrors are gone
there were three defensive lines
held by the Germans and they were named
after vog Narian witches and the first
that was rather thoughtful of our German
friends at that time and the first was
the giesler Stalin and that was the line
through which the men of the Lost
battalion past the second which was
higher up and they did not see that and
the aef and the meuse-argonne the
American Expeditionary Forces did not
get up there and they only got a little
bit beyond the next line this was the
cream Hilda Stellan or cream Hilda
position and that was the main German
line of defense and the third line was
much higher up it was out of the Argonne
forest it was in open country it was way
up and it was called the fryer line or
fri estelle own and this was around the
little town of busa see so there were
the three lines and what happened here
was that the lost battalions men the six
companies going up passed right through
that line they were very fortunate in
that respect they went up with nine
Hodgkiss machine guns which were heavy
French made machine guns they were lucky
to take those guns up they could take
him apart so they could be carried they
did not have mortars they should have
had martyrs captain Nelson holderman who
was the commander of Company K of the 30
seventh which came up the next morning
halderman had nearly a hundred men his
addition to the four hundred and fifty
men going up was important Holderman
wrote a paper at Fort Benning in 1924-25
the infantry school and holderman said
that no group should have gone up
without mortars and with light guns
there were 37 millimeter guns in the
early stages of the meuse-argonne the
men tended to leave the mortars and the
light guns behind him they could have
used them very much up there
unfortunately they were heavy they
were in two parts each each kind of
mortars and the light guns they each
weigh 80 pounds you couldn't carry them
they required carts in the footloose I
should hardly say that but this was the
National Guard division of Missouri and
Kansas they didn't even have the carts
but that's something else the 77th had
its currents but to wheel those things
up through the dense trees and bushes
and ravines and all of that of the
Argonne forest was just too much and the
men didn't take those weapons up but
they did have the nine hot kisses and
they had a great group of French
submachine guns the show show they were
not the best submachine guns they didn't
have Browning's the Browning's didn't
come in until the very last week's of
the meuse-argonne it was a pity that we
didn't have Browning's heavy and lights
but the production of Browning's was
slow and Pershing was always afraid that
the Germans would get one of those
wonderful guns and perhaps copy it I
shouldn't admit this but in World War
two I carried a light browning I didn't
even know how to fire it and I hung it
on her under my cot and it got full of
dust and dirt and when I turned it into
the ordnance officer he said shame on
you and that's my acquaintance with the
brownies but the brownies were good also
for the Korean War they were wonderful
guns and it's a pity that we didn't have
more than the show shows were short I
mean the show shows didn't fire very
many boats and men at 450 which is quite
a few but the Browning's were much
better
so major major whittlesea and Captain
McMurtry in their men passed through the
gays Alicia lung and they came up to the
top of a hill and they gazed down on
what was the charlevoix Valley the
charlevoix Valley if you consider the
image of a tea they were going up to
stem one kilometer they got up there and
there was the charlevoix Valley and it
was the Traverse of the tea and the two
officers looked over there and they knew
exactly where they wanted to place their
troops they would take the reverse slope
of the charlevoix Valley the reverse
slope according to infantry tactics and
it was a very wise place to go if you
had the opportunity was protected from
artillery fire by the north and the
Germans had artillery to the north they
couldn't get down and touch a reverse
slope you were safe up there and they
also noticed that there was a road this
was the bernard ville opera mall road
that ran two thirds of the way up the
north slope of the charlevoix valley and
they decided they would put their men
right below it and this was a good place
to place the men they took them up there
that night the they got up there they
were about it was about five thirty in
the evening they took the men up and the
first thing the men did they were
skilled infantrymen was to dig a hole
which they did with their trench shovels
and sometimes with their bayonets
bayonets i might say parenthetically
were one of the most useless items in
1917-18 in the posters of the time you
always saw someone plunging a vanette
into some poor German and in the stained
glass murals of that post-war period
there's one in the State House in Jeff
City it shows all those people with
upraised baronet's and the poor Germans
have their hands
and they're just about to be killed
don't believe it the bayonet just wasn't
used you couldn't get close enough with
a bayonet the Banat the surgeons rarely
saw a bayonet wounds but to come back to
the lost battalion the men dug their
holes then they ate what little food
they had there was a little more left
over the food then lasted until noon of
the first full day which was October
third and then it ran out and if you
were hungry after that you could eat
roots and grass and think of food it was
the thought of food it was the inability
to have it which Americans of the
present day who don't have this kind of
problem if they are undying they yearn
for nothing but food and then a sort of
just time of weakness set in and the
lack of food was one of the great
problems up there in the pocket they
were on the reverse slope and not merely
could artillery not reach them but they
could not easily be attacked from the
top of the slope that is the north crest
of the charlevoix Valley because there
were open spaces there and then there
was the road that was cut in it ran
parallel with the valley it was cut in
two thirds of the way up and they were
just below the road in the so-called
pocket as it became but you couldn't
easily get down there you know if you
were a German you'd have to go through
these open spaces you had to jump down
on the road and as they came down and
they did once or twice every day from
that direction they were shot by the
people in the pocket with their
springfield's it wasn't too difficult to
get them that was a difficult place to
attack and the Germans tried it and
invariably did not make
They Carried I should say about those
troops that came on came down over the
Kristen they carried potato mashers I
often I think I have to define a potato
measure this had a handle on it and then
there was the bucket in which one puts
the potato shreds it by squeezing the
handle the charge was of course where
the bucket might have been and they
would throw these things as they came
down they were dangerous but not too
dangerous because like the artillery of
the early 19th century you could step
aside as you saw one coming and it would
just continue on down so the Germans
every day came in from the top once or
twice in a major attack and also from
the flanks they did not come in from the
south side of the shower boat Valley
because it was a little creek that ran
down through there this was the
charlevoix Creek and it's uh was marshy
around the creek and there were also too
much too many open spaces so the attacks
came in from the flanks and from the top
each day and was that's where the water
came from the shadow creek the men who
the water carriers whittlesea put out a
word that no one should go down for
water unless he were a carrier and the
carriers went down at night they took a
string of canteens and filled them up as
quietly as they could and the big
problem was to prevent one canteen from
banging against another one which would
hurt the machine gunners who would then
perhaps Farah burst or two and might
cause some real damage because they had
they had the whole Creek under
observation but the water came at night
there wasn't enough of it had there been
more the men might have substituted
water for food but they were perennial e
hungry in part because the water was
scared
I should say that the Germans also had
martyrs there was a heavy mortar which
was finally taken out on the fifth hour
tillery got it and there were two light
mortars the martyrs were fearsome
propositions because they threw their
shells in an arc they were not very
effective because they were difficult to
aim and when the shells came down most
of them were duds only fifteen twenty
percent of those that came into the
pocket actually had charges that worked
so the martyrs were not all that
difficult but they were sort of
horrifying to have coming in on you not
to mention all the machine gun firing
and this is what the men were up against
let me say just a little bit about the
two commanders this was major whittlesea
and Captain McMurtry major Whittlesey
was born Pittsfield Mass attended
Williams College which even now is a
wonderful Ivy League college and then he
went to Harvard Law School and he went
down to Wall Street as so many people
from New England have done that's not an
area that seems to keep its people he
went down to Wall Street and before the
war he was a practicing attorney he had
a partner then when the war came he went
to one of the Plattsburgh schools
so-called instituted by General Leonard
Wood in 1915 and these schools trained
officers and he came out of first
lieutenant and he had risen to major by
the time he took the company's up he was
a tall gangly fellow he wore army
spectacles meaning that there were steel
circles around his eyes he was a very
quiet man it was said of him that he had
the typical quiet of his region I think
people said this because of the 30th
President of the United States who was
John Calvin Coolidge
and coolidge was quiet when he thought
there were people around who might do
him harm coolidge had a whole if I
shouldn't go off on coolies but he had a
whole bunch of amusing sayings and one
was that if you don't say much it won't
hurt you and it was an interesting point
because when he got among friends he
just talked your leg off but he had to
be sure who was around otherwise silent
Cal was silent indeed I whittlesey was
just playing silent he was laconic and
something was with within him that was
not quite adjusted to war he knew it was
necessary but he deplored what was
necessary and there was a story told
after the war which was when he and a
wounded man were in a foxhole together
and he woke up in the middle of the
night and he found that his face had
pressed against the face of the wounded
man and the wounded man's face was cold
he had died whittlesea told that one
several times and something wasn't right
he was also accused of leading these men
into a German trap and this bothered him
very much because he did not do that yes
perhaps literally he did but he didn't
do it on purpose and this all bothered
him and so he and the other two
congressional medal winners one was
Captain McMurtry his second-in-command
the other was Captain holderman who was
commander of K company the three of them
attended the entombment of the Unknown
Soldier which was november 11th 1921 and
after that whittlesea was being put upon
by all kinds of people who wanted him to
do this and do that it was not very kind
of them the Red Cross went after him and
he was the chairman of the red cross
members
drive in greater new york city you could
send in a dollar and become a member of
the Red Cross and that membership drive
went on until Thanksgiving and right
after that he booked passage on a
combination passenger and fruit carrier
liner it was a little small ship named
the toloa and he went aboard on Saturday
morning that night he was sitting in the
cabin had a drink with a friend whom he
met there and around midnight he said he
had to leave and he walked out and was
never seen again jumped over the side
Williams has Williams College has
whittlesea papers which I didn't see
because the archivist properly told me
they don't amount to much but there was
one letter in there and I should have
asked for any letters and my friend Mac
Kaufman who is the leading historian of
World War One max sent me the letter
last week and the first sentence the
rest of it this was to his former law
partner who was his executor listed his
assets rather interesting but the first
sentence said something like these were
not the words said something like I'm
tired of it all and what does that say
that says I think suicide he was a
suicide and then there was Captain
McMurtry who was quite different he was
short stocky ebullient he was full of
talk and the pet phrase of that time
which reminds me that two weeks ago I
attended the First Congregational Church
in Ann Arbor and their the junior pastor
talked to the children and not the first
word but the third or fourth word I
heard and this little talk was the word
cool she said something was cool and I
sort of shuddered that's that's the
buzzword of the moment my advice to you
is that if you want to use good English
don't say something is cool but coming
back to McMurtry he he was full of the
phrase of 1918
which in case you do not know was red
hot something was red hot and he would
go around and he would pat the men on
their backs and tell them how well they
were doing which indeed they were those
that survived and he might well have
told them that they were red hot he too
had an interesting background he had
finished his junior year at Harvard when
war was declared I don't mean World War
one I mean the spanish-american war so
he joined the Rough Riders which was a
combination of Harvard students and
cowboys and he went off to Cuba spent
the summer there that was his summer
vacation and the colonel was Leonard
Wood one of the great figures in the
American military and the lieutenant
colonel was later not much later
President of the United States and you
know who that was Theodore Roosevelt
himself and back he went for his senior
year graduated in the class of 99 went
down to Wall Street and became a
stockbroker and he was very successful
and when he retired in 1938 his
addresses were Park Avenue and Bar
Harbor he lived for 20 years and after
World War Two he attended reunions of
the survivors the local survivors in the
New York area of the lost battalion and
he would put them up to luncheons
there'd be 30 or 40 men and they had a
newsletter that went out and he presided
over at mcmurtry was a great individual
so these were the two men who commanded
this remarkable group of individuals and
here i mean the lost battalion it was
not lost i should add durrin cart the
curator here in this great institution
reminded me of this lost battalion was a
misnomer there was a New York editor who
when he heard from his reporter in
France and he then coined that phrase
lost battalion and he said in a cable
going back send
and lost battalion he knew that he could
put those two words in a newspaper
column and it would attract readers all
over the country that's where that
phrase came from it was not a battalion
there were men from three battalions and
it was not lost because Whittlesey had a
pigeon man who took up 7 pigeons 7 said
the carrier I think because he went
around after World War one and made
talks for which I suppose he received
money he said seven because if I may go
into a little bit of detail 6 he
released they got back all of them and
they all had the coordinates of the lost
battalion everybody knew where it was
300 yards long 60 yards deep there was
no question about where it was it was
not lost but Omer Richards said he
reached into the pigeon crate there were
only two left this was the afternoon of
friday October fourth and the lost
battalion was in a fix at that moment
any reach for a pigeon and the pigeons
didn't want to have hands going in there
and one pigeon fluttered out that meant
that he only had one pigeon to send it
was the last pigeon and someone named
that bird share on me dear friend and
cher ami got back he one of his legs was
broken and it was hanging by a tendon
and on that tendon was the tissue paper
on which on which whittlesea had written
his last message and it was of course
about the short shooting by the 77th
artillery more in that more about that
in a moment and he said for heaven sakes
stop it he said and Cheramie fluttered
off and made it his breast bone was
broken it died of wounds in 1919 it was
promptly stuffed and it's in this month
sickness
sonian it's in a drawer there and I've
been tempted to to go down and see this
dead pigeon but since it's been dead
since nineteen nineteen I'm not sure I
want to see what he looks like now but
he's there somewhere so it was not lost
it was not a battalion it was commanded
by two fine commanders it went through
all kinds of problems in troubles I've
mentioned McMurtry whittlesea and
McMurtry both had steel and their souls
they were wonderful people to command
these men and on the last day that this
was October 7th Monday whittlesea a
German threw a potato measure at him the
charge fell off but the handle went into
his back and he was going around with
that handle of the masher sticking out
his back and believe me when he put his
arm around some man and said do the best
you can all that fellow had to do was to
see that handle sticking out his back
surgeons had to take it out afterward
and so the men endured until Monday
night when the men of the relieving
regiment the 30 seventh came in from the
right flank it was wonderful to hear and
one almost becomes modelling about it I
tend to tears when I think of it they
could hear the whine of the springfields
at the peculiar sound of the show Shaw
and in came those men it was just
wonderful now you might properly ask how
they got in there how they could have
been surrounded and let me briefly say
that's this very quickly the first
problem was that their left flank was
open the French had retreated on the
evening of October second the same
evening that the lost battalion went up
and the tragedy of it all was the
American 92nd division had been attached
attached to the French 4th army and they
weren't used for heaven's sake there
were sixteen thousand rifles in the 92nd
but the 92nd was an african-american
division and the French didn't want it
in their army because the company grade
officers that his company and below were
african-americans and in the French
colonial divisions the company grade
officers and the noncoms were all whites
the senior officers in the 92nd were
white it was said that the 92nd had
failed during the attack of that began
September 26 the first opening attack at
the music on this was not true one
battalion failed but many American of
white battalions failed one battalion
stuck it out but what happened to French
didn't want it they told Pershing to
take it back Pershing who I have to say
unfortunately despite his sobriquet he
was known as black jack he had commanded
black troops in the spanish-american war
when he was a first lieutenant Pershing
took the 92nd out and turned it on the
roads broke it up it was tragic 16,000
rifles and there were only a few hundred
Germans that had surrounded the lost
battalion this would have protected the
left flank the left flank was the basic
problem the second problem was I think
poor artillery support this was a common
problem in the early days of the
meuse-argonne the men didn't quite know
how to handle their guns by the last
attack of the aef which occurred on
which began on November 1 1918 the men
were really good at those guns general
summer all who was in himself and
artillerists he had blown a hole in the
gate of the prison Forbidden City and
Peking in 1900
summerall came on the first Army
artillery commander and he said my god
Mac your artillery which was really
something but we didn't know how to
handle that at that time there was short
firing by the artillery brigade one of
the artillery regiments of the 77th it
came into the sector of the lost
battalion stayed there for an hour and
35 minutes and john mccluskey who was
the brave brigade commander was I think
responsible and I think General Pershing
should have given him a ticket at that
time perhaps back to the United States
and then again there was something else
he could have done he could have thrown
a circle around I think I'm no artillery
expert but I think he could have thrown
a circle around the place where they
lost battalion was something like that
had happened when the 35th got into top
trouble on September 29th first Army
artillery through a protective arc above
the 35th while it sought to reassemble
itself after it had fallen apart
mycoskie didn't do that and then last
and this is my last point there was I
believe a failure of the Wilson
administration and here i mean the
President himself Woodrow Wilson always
comes in in the polls as 5th or 6th and
is always considered a great president I
don't agree with this I think he was a
very poor wartime president production
of war production in 1917-18 during the
first year and really for the entire
time of the participation in the war
this is a year and eight months war
production was very poor there were no
ships that went to see airplanes didn't
come off the lines shells were not
produced munitions production was just
going in at the end of the war artillery
thought Hillary pieces were not produced
the machine gun situation was almost too
late the brownies were only ready in the
last weeks of the war and to this I
think you have to blow for this you have
to blame President Wilson he presided
over war production furthermore the War
Department was in near chaos during the
first year my Gus the first three Chiefs
of Staff were incompetent three one
after another and then in February this
is a sign of what happened in February
of 1918 in came general patency March
who in world war one was I think as
great a man as General Pershing himself
and March turned the whole thing around
pushing in France in the winter of
1917-18 had four divisions they were
twice the size of allied and German
division so you could say that he had
eight but considering that each side
German and Allied had about 200
divisions this wasn't very much and then
March came in and by November of 1918
there were 42 of these huge divisions in
France and Pershing had 29 in the line
that's what March did but it was late
and these people were not very well
trained they just threw them across in
the spring and summer and early fall of
1918 and there was bound to be a loose
end and one of the loose ends was the
lost battalion of October 227 for which
I think the president bore
responsibility it was President Wilson
it was the lack of artillery support and
most of all it was the open left flank
I'd like to have some questions thank
you very much
[Applause]
any questions being a former college
professor I never make mistakes but if
any of you have questions I'd be glad to
try to answer them here's one can you
tell me who controlled the air and did
this have any bearing on those lost me
tiger it indeed did have bearing there
was an aero squadron this was the 50th
it was American not French but the
Germans took control of the air in the
previous battle it was not a great
battle this was in the middle of sep
tember the Americans control the air but
the Germans controlled the air after the
first day and he is the Argonne part of
the problem was whether but part of the
problem also was the very late
foundation of the of the air service and
as a result many of the artillery
commanders did not have any opportunity
to train with planes and they didn't
know what spotting planes could
accomplish this was a sad business and
the Germans had the air after the first
day that's a good question yes with gas
used in this conflict it was used in the
meuse-argonne the Germans used gas all
the time and they did not use it against
the lost battalion it's surprising that
they did not and I might say in regard
to gas that since the Germans were using
it I think there was no reason why the
Americans should not have used it they
didn't use it until the last attack in
the Emir's our gun which began November
one and then they just drenched the
Germans with gas and that together with
the artillery fire just roll them up
like a tin can yeah gas is an
interesting subject the Germans
sometimes use small quantities but just
enough for the men to keep their man
son and those masks were difficult to
fight in and they were debilitating and
they there was a temptation to take them
off and then you were in deep trouble
yeah I like to had question to gas in
the movies Aragon is an interesting
subject yes my father was in the 77th
division how I will I had queried him
more i bought a brick out here and his
name is found on the roster of the lost
battalion so maybe he wasn't there I
don't know I wish I had acquired him
more do you know whether he was in the
307 3308 infantry I do not I probably
could figure that out he has suffered
lung damage from gas so many people did
and received a small by dr. Pynchon i
think it was and you remember all of
this the he told me it was sleeping and
breathing i yes he had terrible trouble
he probably died later from that problem
there were many such cases the problems
with gas lingered on Whittlesey suffered
from gas when he was living in an
apartment after the war the people who
are also near there could hear him
coughing at night there were four
regiments in the 77th there was also an
hour till early brigade and your father
could have been in one of those and only
three companies of the 1st and 2nd
battalions of the 308 went up there was
a fourth company and it wasn't in the
pocket and there were three other
companies of the 30 seventh which were
not in the pocket well there were more
than that but there were many men who
didn't get in it in the 77th my father
was in the meuse-argonne too and it was
the changing experience of their life
that's one of the things that
that great battle 1.2 million were in
men were involved the deaths in the
meuse-argonne were 26,000 it was the
largest battle in American history the
second largest in case you don't know
was Okinawa where the deaths were only
half as many 13 thousand and five
thousand of those were aboard ship one
thousand I'm sorry to retail all this
factual information 1,000 were aboard
the great carrier Franklin one of my
indiana university colleagues was aboard
the franklin he was a flyer and he
jumped overboard and broke his leg that
was his experience but many men died in
those ships and that was the second
largest fatal photography fatalities in
American history twenty-six thousand
engineers Aragon yes my impression from
reading two or three books about World
War one is that depending upon the
nationality of the storian there was the
English who went at French or the
Americans you mentioned in this
particular battle that the French
retreated why and number two what
significance do you believe that the
Americans had on the eventual Allied
victory of 401 tell me that first
question again do you believe that the
Americans had a significant impact upon
winning the war and more specifically
why did the French retreat from this
battle as you mentioned oh yes of-of
course the Americans made the difference
Hindenburg after the war he was not the
field commander Ludendorff was but
Hindenburg and Ludendorff said that it
was the appearance of the Americans my
gosh 42 divisions this made the
difference and it was the meuse-argonne
also where they had 12 1.2 million men
in the line that made a great difference
as to who won the war one might argue
that the British in there at
attack of august eight I think it was
that that was Ludendorff black day as he
described it but the appearance of the
Americans just made all the difference
it was hopeless for Germany after those
great big husky fellows came over two
million of them were there by the end of
the war and this made all the difference
in the world I think that our time is up
and unless there are any more questions
thank you very much
thank you guys affair Robert Farrell is
professor emeritus of history at Indiana
University in Bloomington five days in
october the lost battalion of world war
one accomplished by university of
missouri press on the web at um press
dot edu slash you press